it is true than on Wall Street and among
traders there's a lot of endorphins
being being produced and in fact they've
studied traders in the London Stock
Market London traders and they found
that sure enough that those who take on
significant risks may have increased
levels of testosterone they found
correlation between those high
testosterone and high risk taking and
all and also causation some studies
showed that if you take a nasal spray of
testosterone you're more likely to take
financial risks so it's not just in Wall
Street is also a lot of financial
decisions when you're in a casino right
those who have certain chemicals are
more more likely to take certain
financial decisions well the most
important thing about an investor is
someone who can detach themselves from
irrational activity for example one
investor who I know went to Japan
recently and looked at all kinds of
banks and companies and try to figure
out what she what should he invested in
Japan but when he came home to America
he decided he was not going to invest in
Japan for three to six months and why is
that because he felt that he may be
subject to the availability bias meaning
that the more likely you can recall
something the more familiar you are with
something the more likely you're going
to invest in it that's why people play
the lottery my dad plays a lottery every
single week and ask them dad why do you
play the lottery he says well I see
people winning the lottery on the news
and may I may win it and said well
you're not seeing all them you know
hundreds of thousand people that are
losing so professional investors can
create checklists to serve which they're
rooting out their bias whether it's
things that they can easily remember and
are things that are familiar with and
they can check themselves to make sure
they're not making irrational financial
decisions markets are very volatile when
they're going down is because it
encourages irrational activity when
you're losing money some traders try to
double their bets to try to make up make
up their losses so so they don't realize
losses they want to keep on doubling
down doubling down that's why we have
these incredible trading losses because
some traders or just loose cannons and
there they don't want to lose money they
want to make money so they keep making
irrational financial decisions and
that's when you start
market gradually goes up and then it
plummets when it goes down